heyo we are back and we are so excited
to wind down and talk about this wild
episode I like and our very own Ivonne
orgy is back with us this week to get
into it yeah this weekend was supposed
to be about two things female bonding
and Beyonce this is meant to be like a
girls fun episode is our first time this
season that we really got to get
everybody together episode three was
like a nice little cute little dinner
but this is like the girls in their
element if you're not in your Beyonce
mode you're just busting in yeah but
you're losing why would you wouldn't get
it yeah what would Jesus do or in
Beyonce er but it's kind of like about
copy I think it's a person that we
actually see the girls have a little bit
of a hiccup in their relationship
because usually when the girls together
either Issa or Molly's bringing a
problem to the group and the group is
sort of weighing in on those discussions
whether we are talked about is like how
do we see new dynamics of friendships
and it was nice to have that ISA Tiffany
scene where it was just them in the
parking lot of 7-eleven we see Tiffany
kind of be bougie and throw shade but it
was really nice I thought the man did
such an amazing job in that scene and
you guys both of being like oh she's a
real person she's really having concerns
and doubts in which she's not holding
court amongst all those things this is
how she really is and it really feels it
to me it made me understand oh that's
why they're friends with her you know
and Tiffany we get to see her in a rare
vulnerable oh man I'm just like maybe I
have to ask myself if I'm okay with the
fact that we might not be friends
further and it'll be different and I
have to be okay with that and I think
girls do they have more than guys cuz
you'll see a group of doozie like why
are you so friends with him like I mean
I know this is I was eight well since
you're a man in a row man I'm gonna wear
now the real man
why do you guys not exchange friends
when they make like real existence cuz I
think dudes feel very loyal to people
who knew them when they
kind of had nothing I think this is
where made over our different and I
think that's interesting about our show
is that I think min can have friendships
that they'll say that that's my boy but
we don't really talk we're four girls
that's my girl we talk so I think the
relationships feel charged and more
interesting and more dynamic in a way
that I think men friendships on and
certainly on-screen yeah I even warrants
like Lawrence in our show of being a guy
who was like got cheated on kind of
became introverted as opposed to if
there was a woman they would talk it out
and you sort of say why Chad and
Lawrence why are they friends oh
speaking of Lawrence he's back and it's
gonna be very interesting to see you
know what that means for ISA you know
what was that moment like when you saw
Lawrence at the store oh it was it was a
little reunion I got like butterflies in
my stomach I'm just like oh he's back
because you know Jay hadn't been on set
I'm surprised it was seen Chad make my
stomach turn cuz I really I love Neil
hey Chad
but it was just they felt like a reunion
and we're gonna see next episode that's
one of the things we talked about too in
the room was like when do we reintroduce
Lawrence you know and when do we bring
her back and I think what's interesting
is I think was last season where it's
like as soon as you get a guy loop loop
and that's really what happens it's like
you're here with Nathan and then
bloo-bloop
so thanks for wanting down with us this
week and thanks to the lovely as always
Yvonne orgy
you next time so I have a question is
that have been there that are you you
know what we don't really need to get
into what this is you know what I'm
neutral
I ride both sides you know what
[Music]
you